[Music]
there's been a secret under the streets
of Liverpool for hundreds of years
a mysterious network of tunnels built
200 years ago and stretching on for
miles was built by eccentric and
successful tobacco merchant Joseph
Williamson there's evidence of tunnels
built and then immediately bricked back
up again and arches that lead to nowhere
but the purpose and the reason behind
building these is unknown there's
theories of course one that he and his
wife were part of an apocalyptic cult
and these tunnels were to be their
hideout another that its only aim was to
provide jobs for the men in the area to
combat the high levels of unemployment a
final theory is they were used for
smuggling for other secret operations by
Williamson himself construction on the
tunnels stopped immediately after
Williamson's death may 1840 and it
wasn't rediscovered until 2001 since
then a team of local retirees has made
it their mission to excavate the tunnels
but with no records to offer explanation
the purpose of the tunnels we're even
map of how far they span has made it
mysterious and tough job
[Music]